Welcome back everyone it's Charlie
Ahsoka is getting started and a lot
of you have been asking questions about Hayden
Christensen coming back Anakin Skywalker other
Jedi characters after the trailer was released
Hayden Christensen has appeared online in cast
list for the show so I'll explain what's going
on with him during the events of the Ahsoka series
if you're brand new to the channel I'll be doing
weekly episode videos for Ahsoka just like the
Mandalorian the other Star Wars series be sure
to subscribe to get them I will do a special
Ahsoka giveaway during those when they start
releasing the episodes careful for spoilers for
everything on the mandalorians so far if you
haven't caught up with the episodes but one of
the cool things about the Ahsoka series that's
been missing from the Mandalorian is a lot of
Jedi characters so they've been flashbacks to
some of the what's happening during Order
66 the Jedi Temple there's been some Jedi
stuff happening related to grogu storyline
like some Luke Skywalker cameos which is
obviously a very big deal some Ahsoka cameos
I've only known one other being like this
A wise Jedi master named Yoda
it belonged to my teacher Master Yoda but one
of the reasons why you haven't seen a ton of
Jedi stuff happening on the Mandalorian is because
there aren't that many Force users active in the
Galaxy during that part of the timeline so when
Dave filoni John Favreau plotted out the way the
Mando verse works with all the different spin-off
shows they knew they'd be doing an Ahsoka series
and she's probably the biggest Force user around
right now next to Luke Skywalker so it just made
sense for them to do a lot of their Jedi related
stuff during the Ahsoka series and only doing a
little bit during the Mandalorian for grogu
storyline so like all the classic Jedi stuff
you'd expect when you hear they're going to
be Jedi characters showing up like deep Force
lore that's going to the Ahsoka series typically
when you hear Jedi characters are going to appear
during a series or even dark force use any kind
of force users you're thinking a big lightsaber
fights you're thinking about cool new Force lore
from the books or from the expanded universe that
Dave balloon is bringing back most of that is
coming through the Ahsoka series that's why
during the Ahsoka trailer we're seeing so much
more Jedi dark force users stuff like thousand
percent more than we saw in the Mandalorian so far
this is a new beginning for some War for others
it's going to be at least another 20 to 30
years minimum before grogu is about the same
size as Yoda like fully matured walking around
and talking the gigachad version of Yoda and
that'd be way past the Mandalorian season finale
like even if it goes for seven to ten Seasons it
would be well past that he'll have long since
gone to some other TV series or movie by then
like don't worry there will be plenty of grogu
for the rest of your natural born life but you
can see how the shows have been bringing Hayden
Christensen back more and more Obi-Wan Kenobi is
just the most recent biggest play so far coming
back as both Anakin Skywalker and flashbacks and
Darth Vader in the present day of that series
your pain has just begun that was meant to be
taking place about 10 years after Revenge of the
Sith the report at the time when we learned he was
first coming back for that was that he had signed
a deal that was much larger like a deal with the
option open to come back in the Ahsoka series
and do other things in different parts of the
timeline the twist with the Ahsoka series though
is that the present day of the series is set for
during the same time period as the Mandalorian
after returning the Jedi during the events of
season three were about nine years after Return
of the Jedi so a little bit of time has gone by
since the events of season one that was meant to
be about five years after Return of the Jedi there
are a couple scenes during the Ahsoka trailer
that make it seem like we'll see a few smaller
time jumps during that like the scene right here
is meant to be the exact same scene from the Star
Wars Rebels ending just in live action and it's
Ahsoka coming in her ship after the second death
star was destroyed at the end of Return of the
Jedi to pick up Sabine Wren who had been fighting
in the Rebellion during the original trilogy
that's a bit of a retcon because obviously she
debuted during Star Wars Rebels but Dave filoni
said that she was part of the Rebellion during
the events of the original trilogy and after
returned the Jedi she came back to lothal and
she's just been chilling out here stewing thinking
about Ezra Bridger that's why her hair has grown
longer but it's shorter during other parts of the
trailer because when Ahsoka comes to get her she
cuts her hair again and that's after Ahsoka has
learned the grand admiral thrawn has returned and
even though they don't know where Ezra Bridger is
they assume that that means that he's come back
to so they're also looking for him but they're
also trying to stop Grand Admiral thrawn and I
think that scene is meant to be happening around
the time that season one of the Mandalorian is
happening like a couple years after at least four
or five years after returning the Jedi so a little
bit of time has gone by then I think at some point
the main part of the Ahsoka series will take place
closer to present day like it'll catch up with
the events of the Mandalorian which is closer
to nine years later like another four years after
this moment here where Ahsoka comes back together
so not massive time jumps but a little bit of time
jumping and since we just saw the Obi-Wan Kenobi
episodes and during the Mandalorian we've seen a
bunch of time jumps like we saw a bunch of grogu
flashbacks to order 66 to learn about who saved
him Keller and Beck Ahmed best coming back and
we saw the Obi-Wan Kenobi flashbacks with Anakin
Skywalker much further earlier in the timeline
when he was still whole before order 66. naturally
it makes sense that Ahsoka would also have some
kind of flashbacks to address her history and the
major moments of her life for example Ahsoka left
the Jedi Order a few years before or Order 66
probably one of the most defining moments of her
life it was like grogu choosing to leave Luke
Skywalker's Jedi Academy if he'd been at Luke
Skywalker's Jedi Academy for much much longer the
Obi-Wan Kenobi Anakin Skywalker flashback wasn't
necessarily to a defining moment it was just
one of their many lightsaber training sessions
like a lesson that Obi-Wan Kenobi gave to him
during their time together but because his hair
is so short that's just meant to tell you that
it's during the events attack of the Clones or
around that period just because he still has
the Padawan haircut Ahsoka didn't actually
become Anakin Skywalker's Padawan until after he
became a full Jedi Knight and started wearing his
hair longer so many Ahsoka Anakin flashbacks
first Snips and Sky Guy moments like you see
Rosario Dawson posting pictures here at the recent
Star Wars celebration convention like hey Sky guy
how's it going Snips any flashbacks for stuff like
that would have to be between the Clone Wars and
before the second half of Revenge of the Sith the
scene at the end of the Clone Wars where Anakin
gives her her twin lightsabers back that she had
left with the Jetta order when she left happened
around the middle of Revenge of the Sith like
Ahsoka was on her way back to Corson after
retaking the Mandalore Planet helping Bo Katan
like we just saw them retake Mandalore that scene
was happening right as the emperor was executing
Order 66 like they were in hyperspace on their way
back to Coruscant when that went down so there's a
little bit of overlap between those last couple of
episodes of The Clone Wars season 7 and Revenge of
the Sith the other major flashback scene that they
can do probably one of the best scenes in all
of Star Wars even live action is their reunion
after he had become Darth Vader during Star
Wars Rebels during Twilight of The Apprentice
the events of rebels was when she finally learned
that Anakin Skywalker had become Darth Vader she'd
been hiding out in the outer rim after Order
66 went down and eventually started working
for bail Organa in the Rebellion is fulcrum sort
of like a point of communications between Rebel
cells through the events of Star Wars Andor
so when the events of Andor are taking place
and you see the Rebellion start to come together
Ahsoka is actually helping them in the background
full crime Ahsoka my name is Ahsoka Tano then the
events of Star Wars Rebels picks up towards the
end of Andor and that's when she started becoming
more active more public again and working with
the crew of the ghost which we're all going to
see in live action like we just saw Zeb on the
Mandalorian and we see all the other characters
come back during the Ahsoka trailer so that whole
period between Revenge of the Sith and Rebels she
thought that Anakin Skywalker had been dead she
never spoke to Obi-Wan Kenobi he never had the
chance to tell her because they were trying to
stay hidden like that's why they didn't spend all
that time talking to each other early on in Rebels
she started to have visions of Anakin Skywalker's
Darth Vader so she started to figure things out
but it wasn't until Twilight of The Apprentice
when they had their face-to-face reunion and she
gets the confirmation like she sees it with her
own eyes oh my God what's happened to you Anakin
I won't leave you, not this time
then you will die
the actual title of that episode
Twilight of The Apprentice was also reference to
her being Anakin Skywalker's Apprentice Ezra
Bridger wound up using the world Between Worlds
to pull Ahsoka out of that part of the timeline
into his present day so she did wind up skipping
a good chunk of time there but Ahsoka could also
have a flashback to her reunion with Darth Vader
also during the Ahsoka trailer this place also
kind of seems similar to the world Between Worlds
and what I'm really hoping for you know fingers
crossed is that during present day we'll see
Hayden Christensen come back as Force ghost
Anakin Skywalker to speak with Ahsoka we've
actually seen Force ghost Anakin Skywalker a
couple times in Canon at the end of Return of
the Jedi then during the rise of Skywalker when
they're killing the emperor you hear Force ghost
voices from a ton of Jedi characters including
Kanan jarus they included pretty much every single
big Jedi character you could think of from the
Canon so Hayden Christensen recorded new voiceover
dialogue as Anakin Skywalker's Force goes for
this the Star Wars people also revealed that
there was talk of Anakin Skywalker's Force ghost
being the one to appear to older Luke Skywalker
during return the Jedi instead of Yoda the reason
they said they went with Yoda instead of Anakin is
just because he was more important for the context
of this scene because Yoda had been Luke's Jedi
Master so they had actually been trying to bring
back forsko's Anakin Skywalker for many years now
the Ahsoka series would be the perfect place for
that to happen we might even get some more Force
goes kananjara scenes talking to Ezra Bridger as
the force wolf Doom there's a picture of a loath
wolf behind Sabine here that she drew that could
be a clue that we'll see the loath wolves during
the series it also seems like kanan's son with
Hera Jason will be part of the series so there's
just a lot of reasons to include cameos from him
as well it's just that he'd have to be a force
ghost let me know in the comments though if they
only have eight episodes and they're about the
same length as the Mandalorian they'll probably
do about as many flashbacks as the Mandalorian the
Obi-Wan Kenobi series did what kind of scenes
do you want to see with Hayden Christensen
Ewan McGregor was also talking about Obi-Wan
Kenobi season 2 at Star Wars celebration but
lucasfone claims that they're not actively
working on it but they might wind up doing
it in the future Hayden Christensen will also
come back is Darth Vader and Anakin Skywalker
flashbacks for that too Darth Vader would only
be in his late 30s during that period so he'd
still be very very active we'll get another Ahsoka
trailer soon that'll give us more of the actual
Story the first trailers are mostly just meant to
be teasers that show you some of the characters
some of the locations like teasing the return of
grand Admiral thrawn in his new mystery Fleet of
capital ships we might see a cameo from grogu
in the Mandalorian during Ahsoka I think part
of the reason for the armor sending him away
to do groco's Journeys and becoming a bounty
hunter for the new Republic in the outer rim was
to make it easier to explain how they could run
into the Ahsoka characters if you have any other
questions or requests for bonus videos for Ahsoka
just leave them in the comments below everyone
click here for my Mandalorian season 4 teaser
video and all my Mandalorian episodes and click
here for my Ahsoka trailer in Easter eggs thank
you so much for watching everyone and stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!